Why do we sometimes fail to perform
up to ourpotential under pressure?
We often get in our own way
precisely because our worries
promptus to concentrate too much.
So what do we do? A lot of it comes
down to the prefrontalcortex,
that front part of our brain
that sits over our eyes
and usually helps us focusin positive ways.
It often gets hooked on the wrong things.
So how do we unhook it?
Something as simple as singing a song,
can help us take our mind
off those pesky details.
It's also true that practicing under conditions
that we're going to perform under --
closingthe gap between
training and competition
can help us get used to
that feeling of all eyes onus.
When you're taking a test, close the book,
practice retrieving the answer from
memoryunder timed situations.
The ability to get used to
what it will feel like
can make thedifference in
whether we choke or thrive.